for anyone interested the first pursuit
of wonder short story collection book is
now available
comprised of 31 short stories from
videos posted on the channel
you can find it in both print and ebook
through the links in the description
below
at the base of a large pit in the
mountains of the cascade range
surrounded by 360 degrees of tall steep
rock wall
there lived a small bale of pond turtles
allowing the turtles to stay alive at
the base water regularly seeped up from
an aquifer
and formed into little pools that they
could drink from a small amount of
various vegetation and insects shared
the pit as well
which they could eat from although this
kept most alive
the turtles suffered because of their
condition resources weren't necessarily
limited
but competition that formed around them
often rendered them limited
generally at best they were
uncomfortable constantly oscillating
into hunger and thirst
hot or cold bored or anxious the turtles
often fought with each other
they often got sick all eventually in
some respect
all eventually dying the surviving
forced to watch
they all felt trapped caught in this pit
of misery with nothing to ever fully
satiate their desires
and free them from their pains naturally
nearly all the turtles felt an innate
yearning to escape the pit
and spread out into the beyond above
them the bliss beyond their confines
the freedom however the walls were far
too tall for them to climb
and so the early generations remained
stuck
suffering around this early time many
members would discuss
various ideas and philosophies
surrounding the goal of escaping
all with no true avail as time would
pass
compelled by impulses and drives that
culminated into a sort of lust slinging
process
some of the early generation turtles
inadvertently reproduced
bringing more turtles into the pit
eventually one of the more astute elder
turtles came up with an idea
it figured out that with enough turtles
they could all stack on top of each
other
in a sort of ramp-like configuration and
allow some of the turtles at the top to
climb out
and be freed the turtle shared this idea
with the bale
and after some convincing everyone was
on board
now with the insight that having
offspring could help solve their problem
and alleviate their suffering the
turtles began reproducing intentionally
with this in mind
birthing new turtles into the pit on
purpose
as soon as the bale had enough offspring
and the offspring matured to large
enough size
the turtles all stacked on each other in
a sort of a skew ramp configuration
all the way up to the top of the wall
for the first time
several turtles made their way out of
the pit and into the beyond
above it following these several turtles
climbing out however
the remaining turtles would soon find
themselves without enough turtles left
to climb high enough
and so they all climbed back down into
the pit again
now knowing that the process worked
though they began birthing more
offspring with the intention of freeing
more of themselves
a system of sorts was established and
embraced wherein
the eldest turtles would be the ones
designated to leave first
in order of their age leaving the
remaining younger turtles to wait their
turn
and continue reproducing occasionally
there were also certain younger turtles
who
through either force perceived
importance flukes in the system
persuasion or all of the above made
their way out
sometime earlier in general the cycle of
the system would be accepted and
repeated over and over
generation after generation more
offspring brought into the pit
only to work the first two thirds of
their life to survive and hope that they
would make it into the eldest position
and finally climb out finally find their
reason and pay out for it all
finally become a member of their bale
who made it finally touch some state of
freedom
ultimately throughout the whole process
almost every turtle was born
in some sense to help solve their
parents problem their parents problem
becoming theirs
the new turtles eventually becoming
compelled to birth more offspring
to help solve what now became their
problem and then repeat
a part of a later generation one turtle
in particular
who was not particularly unique at all
and in fact was like many others in its
view
often found itself questioning was it
all worth the hassle
was the measure of pain worth the
potential pleasure of the payoff
was everything worth the trouble of
being born
it wondered and struggled with these
questions which ultimately made it
question whether it should participate
in the whole system
was it fair to birth more turtles to do
the same simply to potentially make
things better for itself
in hopes that its offspring would find
this agreeable
of course this turtle was aware that
some turtles found value in the whole
thing
meaning in the pit the pursuit of
getting out and the occasional pleasures
along the way
but this particular turtle found these
other turtles to be delusional
at best it only envied them knowing that
it could never really see its life this
way
and find sufficient justification in the
suffering
ultimately this turtle realized only the
individual could decide
for themselves if it was better or worse
to have been born into the pit or not
but it also realized that the paradox
was that the individual could only
decide once they were born
and it was too late not to be
to this day the turtles continue on in
the pit some ignoring this issue
some unaware some struggling or in
revolt with it
in some distance of some future perhaps
the turtles will figure out a way for an
ultimate and total escape of their
entire population
and hopefully for their sake outside the
pit
is what they've hoped for but for now
the general suffering
it's turtles all the way down
[Music]
as mentioned at the beginning of the
video for anyone interested in having
the short stories from the channel in
print or ebook format
the first pursuit of wonder short story
collection book is now available
titled the hidden story of every person
the book contains 31 stories from the
channel including the nova effect
the last thought you'll ever have the
beginning and end of humanity
and 28 more all in re-edited updated and
revised form
for anyone who prefers reading over
listening or enjoys having a physical
print copy of written work
or would just like to have a piece of
the channel to revisit through this will
hopefully
be a value to you if you're interested
you can see all the stories that are
included
and purchase your copy using the links
in the description below
for anyone who does get a copy thank you
so much in advance
the support always sincerely means a
great deal and of course
thank you for watching and supporting
the channel in general and any and all
of the ways you have
see you next video